[Music]
adam is in san antonio hey adam welcome
to the ramsey show
hey there mr randy how are you doing
today great man what's up
hey i had a question for you sir and uh
first i wanted to say thank you so much
for your time um i used to be myself 114
000 in debt in 2017 three years and two
months later it's paid off way to go man
awesome yes sir
thank you so much yeah thanks to you and
a cousin i have named kevin who uh
always kept talking about you i stopped
being stubborn one day and gave them
okay i appreciate it sir
yes sir
and um i wanted to ask you a question
i've listened to your show quite a few
times and i haven't i'm sure there's an
instance and i probably missed it but um
my mom is 68 and i just wanted to ask on
her behalf your advice so she hasn't
saved for retirement
um
she has 18 000 in her 401k
um 60k in cash
her home is valued i think approximately
in the low 500s right now and she owes
about 205 on it
and
she's at that point right now i've been
watching it happen for a while where
eventually it was going to get to this
point of you know what do i do next and
so
um tried to talk to my mom about it but
she she didn't want to talk about it so
you can only talk to someone if they
want to talk about it so i just wanted
to ask your advice sir she asked me for
some advice this morning and
you know i think probably the lord put
you on mine so i just thought i would
call in and just get your advice and see
what you do if you're in this situation
wow that's a tough one man
uh how much does she make
she's making about 70 000 right now she
hit past a normal retirement age for
social security so she's able to
take the social security benefit while
still being able to work um full-time so
she's been bringing in from that that's
an additional
um
2000 or 2200 a month on top of the base
seven what is she doing right now
she is a nurse a registered nurse
used to work in the hospital running the
or but now that's too physically
intensive on her so right now she's
doing some medical claims billing work
um
working from home that require
that she can still do you know allows
her to sit and so forth
okay
well i mean
the same principles the same principles
apply uh we've got to get her out of
that and build an emergency fund and
build a nest egg
and i don't know how we're going to do
that on this income
at this age
um
it's not impossible
but the uh um
you know my guess is she's probably
going to downsize in house
and where does she live
she lives in uh weatherford texas in the
dallas fort worth area okay
um if i could find a 300 000 condo that
i could pay cash for
and move her out of that house that'd be
if i were her
i'd look at doing that and let's get the
housing paid for then all we've got to
do is just pile up cash with the
remaining work gears for nest egg
yes sir
i don't know how you're going to support
a 205 000 mortgage on social security
yes sir um if you don't mind me asking
one big question on top of that it's
still tied to the exact same issue um
my brother-in-law has quite a bit of
land and did offer her uh to possibly
build a tiny home on that land
um now
you want to build a tiny home you have
to build a tiny home you got 300 grand
right
right i wouldn't build i wouldn't build
it to hold on to no i wouldn't build a
tiny home because there's no there's no
no resale for them there's no market
proven it's a fad
it may prove out later to not be a fad
but for right now it's a fad because
there's no resale on them
yes sir
so i wanna i wanna do real estate deals
that go up in value and then i can live
in long long term but for a couple
hundred thousand bucks she could put a
really nice property if he'll donate the
land to her
sell the house take some of the equity
and build a nice house a good house
doesn't have to be a tiny house and it's
paid for then
it needs to be deeded to her the
property needs to be deeded to her
so he needs to cut out a parcel
a acre or something and give mom an acre
and then she builds a house on it uh by
the and uses the proceeds to sell from
hers that'll help a lot
and if she built that for 200 then she's
got an extra 100 because she's got 300
equity throw that in there to start an
estate and then pile on that nest take
george that'll work yeah i'm not relying
on social security though to fund my
retirement and not with a 200 000
mortgage that house is gone it's not
gonna make this cut